[Musik]
ich war damals gerade als junger und das
ist hier das erste mal im einsatz und
war hat mein einsatzgebiet war im
wipptal also das toll innsbruck brenner
im botschaft steinach war mein
einsatzort wo sie seien aufgelaufen als
bauwerk wissen weil die firma in konkurs
gegangen so die sorge haben wir gezogen
und hatten den auftrag gibt
mit sämtlichen bela die zur grenze
führen mit silbergarn ich muss das so
viele fehler auf die grenze führen toten
zu überwachen die ausnahme war nur
obernberg bei obernberg hat eine eigenen
halb zug bekommen und torten dieses
gebiet einen oberbayern sehen zu
überwachen
kontrolliert wurde in einem mischsystem
zwischen stehenden und patronen weil es
war bei uns verschlag abhängig der
witterung mehr haben wir sind ja im
november gegangen und haben natürlich
erst einmal schnee und kälte das große
problem war die kälte unternehmer dazu
haben hinaus vor partituren mit meine
leute waren immer auch bis zehn stunden
teilweise unterwegs haben sich auch
selber müssen irgendwie tag legen und
haben lange anfahrtswege cup gerade
einmal 2000 einfahren
bis hinten hinein da waren gleich mit
dem haflinger bis dahin unter vier
stunden gefahren und so war das
natürlich immer der ganze einsatz teil
in einer rotation einmal noch besser war
schönes wetter konnte man petroleum
gehen was schlechtes werden hat man nur
beobachtungsposten hintern aber nebel
trennen bedingt es musste also immer
permanent der einsatz dieses schema
verändert worden war und eine zweite
woche des macht es und es wurde auch als
gründen der sicherheit und dass man mit
den plan konnten aus verfolgen wie
laufen unsere patronen wurden wie immer
in der zeit und in der länge verändert
wir haben zum beispiel alle 14 tage bei
minus 18 grad gehabt wir waren also in
steina schon auf 1000 meter und hinten
die ganzen kontroll gebete waren
zwischen 1500 und 2000 meter wir haben
also die billigste fred händler wandel
wenn man damals fördert mit haben
darunter wäsche geburt man sich
teilweise strich gesunken
und bringen lassen oder unter haben
kriegt oder nicht haben als untere sie
haben wir nix körpers mit dem
trainingsanzug wir haben darunter zu
bewahren und an horoskop teilweise mit
gamaschen es war es sehr schwierig und
man muss immer schauen dass die leute
mit den erklärungen des römer beauftragt
das gruppen kommandanten zu schauen
das mit erklärungen haltbar erweisen
außen oder die orangen angefahren das
war gang und gäbe war das haben wir
gerade die kappe hammerkopf beste
schildkappe im haushalt nach europa
klappbares bin und es war ich sehr
problematisch weil die leute hat zwar
weder an ford hat weil da ist die stadt
hat versucht permanent zu gehen und sich
beim zu halten
aber da ist natürlich wieder durch wenn
du durchs kaposvar echtes problem weil
wir haben die flasche körpers metall hat
bei uns gegeben
die war spätestens in drei stunden das
wird mal ausland eingefroren weil dann
wie das auch in gartow mama 20 bis 22
grad gab es sehr schwierig die kälte
erinner permanentes hat ich habe das am
anfang nicht geglaubt dass die kälte zu
belasten die leute waren dann auch fix
und fertig aber von der kälte des opfers
marschieren darf man nichts aber wir
sind fertig weil die kälte und so
richtig aus glaubt hat nur noch bis zur
ogs und will dort ein rein kommst